Anna Navarro on The View
is attacking the Cowboys owner Jerry
Jones she wants answers okay she's going
after the real stories
not about
the Twitter corruption not about the
Biden Administration corruption not
about no just go after the real stories
uh when Jerry Jones was 14 he's 80 years
old now by the way when Jerry Jones was
14
he was photographed near a rally about
segregation
LeBron James gave an interview
um or maybe it was Wednesday I thought
was so incredibly poignant where he
brought up the picture from 1957 of
Jerry Jones the owner of the of the
Dallas Cowboys
um standing in Arkansas uh as a mob of
white boys were blocking black students
from going into a high school
and you know LeBron made the point that
he gets all these questions about Kyrie
Irving about everybody else about all
these things and he said you know what
you guys haven't asked me about Kyrie
Irving about Jerry Jones and why the
disparate attention and I do think it's
important and I hope that Jerry Jones
who has so many black players who has
such a platform who has all this money
who's got all this access I hope Jerry
Jones really does take the opportunity
to to own this to talk about it to
explain it and to talk about the change
that has happened in 65 years and his
role he claims he was just a casual
Observer at that time and and yeah he
was 14 he was a casual Observer right
the best part of it is sunny who who
acknowledges she has to admit here look
maybe he was just there there was a
crowd of people watching something maybe
he was so maybe he was a casual Observer
and also he was 14. he was a child he
was in what ninth or eighth grade or
ninth grade
but there are 14 year olds in the KKK
are are there maim okay maybe
the conservatives must be
the most virtuous people the American
conservatives in the year 2022. must be
some of the most virtuous people ever to
walk the earth
if this is the best the Democrats can do
if the if the best that the Democrats
can do to come up with a scandal about
American conservatives is that
66 years ago
the Dallas Cowboys owner when he was in
ninth grade
was in a crowd of people watching
an event about set desegregation
if that's the best they've got they
don't have anything that they can point
to that they can complain about any time
in the intervening 66 years man we must
be doing something right because I can
point to Democrat corruption right now
that's going on right now in a really
really egregious way that is causing all
sorts of problems that is causing deaths
in some cases when we're talking about
the coveted lockdown regime all sorts of
other problems and the best they've got
and this is true this isn't just about
Jerry Justice this is all they ever talk
about well you know
Jim Crow there was Jim Crow there was
Jim when was Jim Crow oh my gosh man was
it 70 years ago yeah and that's why you
need to give us all this power now and
we need to kick you out of the Public
Square because there was slavery there
was when was slavery that was 150 years
ago that's the best you've got
okay keep keep talking about all the
problems from over a century ago we're
going to keep pointing out the the awful
things that you're doing right in the
here and now we'll see who the people
side with we know who the people will
side with that's why they got to rig the
system that's why they feel that they've
got to rig the system because if the
Democrats felt that they could win fair
and square they wouldn't have to rig the
Public Square and they wouldn't have to
change all of the election rules in
contravention of state constitutions
Barack Obama
just
just said something very interesting and
I I almost have never said that I never
thought Barack Obama was a particularly
interesting public speaker I know when
he came on the scene in 2008 people said
he was the greatest order since Pericles
I never saw that I just thought he said
empty platitudes in a largely boring way
his most famous speech was there's not a
red America not a blue America not
States of America not a Black America
not a white America it's not and you
just think okay okay this is
this is the most banal kind of
platitudeness thing I've ever heard in
my life but he at least
has presented himself as this great
speaker and he does always choose his
words carefully and while campaigning
for Raphael Warnock he took a shot
and Uncle Joe
we all know some folks in Our Lives who
we don't wish them ill will
they say crazy stuff we're all like well
you know Uncle Joe you know what
happened to him
you know it's okay he they're part of
the family
but you don't give him serious
responsibilities
uh he's talking about crazy Uncle Joe
that's a little awkward and the way that
Liberals are reacting to this is to say
oh come on give me a break he wasn't
talking about Joe Biden
he was talking no he was just saying it
all he was just using crazy Uncle Joe to
mean you know whoever you're you're a
random Uncle I'm not he's not talking
about Joe Biden
I'm not convinced of that whatever you
want to say about Barack Obama I have
plenty mean things that I could say
about Barack Obama the man generally
does not misspeak
in fact as crazy Uncle Joe said during
the 2008 primaries Barack Obama is very
articulate I think I think he was Joe
Biden who said that Barack Obama was the
first clean articulate black man in
American politics okay so so you can
take Joe's words for it too crazy Uncle
Joe Barack Obama is precise about his
diction
I I think if for anyone who is paying
attention this was a clear shot at Joe
Biden because in recent weeks you've
seen Joe Biden signaling he does not
want to get out of the way in 2024 that
he does want to run again
a lot of Democrats don't want him to run
again and so what does Barack Obama do
in this thinly veiled Barb he says you
know when you got crazy Uncle Joe Uncle
Joe is Joe Biden's nickname when you got
crazy Uncle Joe you don't you're nice to
him you know he's in the family but you
don't give him a lot of responsibilities
you don't do that
insinuating perhaps that Joe Biden
doesn't have a lot of responsibilities
now he's just being sort of LED around
by the hand and certainly I think
implying that Joe Biden should not have
a lot of responsibilities come 2024. so
who is running the show
who will be the titular head in 2024
but even now if Joe Biden doesn't have a
lot of responsibilities who's running
the show
who is actually enforcing enforcing our
morality who are the morality police
who is the executive in the United
States is Barack Obama seems to suggest
it ain't the president you know the rest
of the show continues now all right and
this is a music Monday baby
I told the guys I said no more rap okay
we've done enough rap let's hold off on
the wrap for a little bit or I've had
I've had enough
so they're they're going to take me back
to the 90s they're going to take me back
to the 90s and early 2000s by playing a
little alternative rock okay so I'm
going to bleach my tips in between now
and the members block I'm going to get
out some nice quick silver and Billabong
clothing throw out throw out a
skateboard and meet you guys over at the
member block if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]